foreign
Cecilia is in Atlanta to start off this
hour hi Cecilia how are you
hey Dave I'm great thanks good how can
we help
so I'm interested in whether or not I
should Leverage
equity lines for more property
when I've tried to not have debt
and is that safe
for investment property activity
okay you realize your sentences just ran
against each other right I mean okay
that's possible I don't want any debt
should I go into debt
no I mean that was what you just told me
I'm confused okay okay
based on there are many many people
buying homes and then getting lines of
equity to buy additional homes as
investment properties and then they have
this whole domino
of yeah their equity lines being leaning
on other properties I I think it's been
spending a lot of time on Tick Tock
haven't you
no I'm a realtor and I I hear others I
hear other people saying this so I did
how long have you been a realtor
five years
um love it
um good so I I know that you kind of had
a history of being in real estate and
not not eventually being good for you
and so I don't know if you're firm on
that or if the current real estate has
been great to me borrowing on real
estate about destroyed me
so what I did as I got caught up in the
same kind of crap that's floating around
out there right now it was happening in
the early 80s uh only it was a different
world obviously we didn't have the
internet instead we had these wonderful
things called infomercials where some
goober is sitting by the surf selling
tapes and a three thousand dollar
weekend course on how to buy real estate
nothing down it was the exact same crap
as all over the place right now
especially on tick tock tick tock's got
a real version of it going okay borrow
all you can because real estate's always
awesome you're always going to make
money it's passive income says the get
rich quick gurus okay now I did that I
started from nothing I was 22 years old
I got four million dollars worth of real
estate by the time I was 26 over a
million dollar net worth meaning I owed
3 million on four million dollars that's
not a bad Equity position at all I had a
lot of short-term notes because I was
doing flips before there was Chip and
Joanna to tell us how and um so I
actually did it I've owned over 2 000
pieces of property in my life so I'm not
inexperienced at this and uh the bank
got scared and called our notes the
Second Bank got when we were in trouble
and called our notes and I had nine I
had 120 days to come up with a million
too and it was all in real estate and I
had no cash because I believed in
leverage because that's what I had been
taught by the get rich quick people does
that any of that sound familiar
I have clients and I don't want to
counsel them incorrectly yeah so here's
the here's the thing so here let me tell
you the end of the story and and then
I'll tell you my answer and so you
understand the why to my answer okay and
the story was I went broke I spent two
and a half years of my life losing
everything I owned one year I made 250
000 at 27 years old the next year I'm my
taxable income was six thousand dollars
I spent the whole year selling
everything to keep it from being
foreclosed on still some of it got
foreclosed on and at the end of the day
two and a half years later I was
bankrupt because they called her because
they were coming to take the baby
furniture out of my house and I was done
with them okay now that's the end of my
story however the other part of the
story was there was a guy named Robert
Allen who would have been on Tick Tock
today if he were still a thing he wrote
a book called nothing down and he
famously would be dropped into any City
without his wallet and buy a house with
no identification or credit of any kind
within 48 hours there's a goober out
there or two doing that on Tick Tock
right now modeling after him okay and so
he would do this I remember watching him
do it in Chicago he did 48 Hours he
bought three houses nothing down okay
and he did this his next book was called
creating wealth he went all over America
starting real estate clubs called acre
and each of these clubs were to feed him
leads to buy more real estate nothing
down I was in one of those clubs because
I was buying nothing down a bunch of us
there was ended up being 160 people in
our investing Club later Robert Allen
filed chapter 11 bankruptcy the whole
thing caught up and took him out too but
anyway
of the guys 130 of them or so in that
club
uh now 30 years ago the number of them
that did not that still own any rental
real estate is about six the rest of
them have gone broke the six that still
own it paid it off and got out of debt
they did not get rich doing this crap
no one makes it a decade doing this crap
it's crap don't do it was that unclear
very clear
you walked into it didn't you Cecilia
to answer this question I'm curious what
is driving you toward this are you doing
are you not great financially
no I I took a little course called
Financial Freedom Financial uh Peace
University and I got debt free paid off
my mortgage paid off my children's
student loans with my husband
what's making you just all the people
doing it that are wanting you to do this
uh no I'm I'm trying I have very much
ignored all the all that clamor
um so I I did when I diversify my
portfolio until you asked me a question
about leveraging lines of credit to go
by real estate you ignored it
well I'm that's why I'm talking to you
it's because I haven't done anything
foolish I know I know but I'm just
saying on it yeah yeah who who what was
it that made you think that that was
even a good idea
that's what George was asking well I
guess my question was had something
changed
and no nothing changes
to get around stuff you know my my dad
lived some of what you're talking about
as well he bought you know land he
couldn't afford and
um hope to hold on to it thinking it's
gonna
turn around and I'm going to make the
zoodles on it because a builder is going
to want it and 20 years later that had
not yet happened he died before he saw
any of that happen so I will tell you
the other part of the end of the story
The the end of the end of the end of the
story
um I after I went broke we started uh
saving money and investing and I used
some of that money to buy a piece of
real estate cash and they then I used
some of that income to buy another piece
of real estate cash and then in 2008
when everything Dove down I had a big
pile of cash and I bought a bunch of
stuff for 15 cents on the dollar
today I own
probably 450 500 million dollars worth
of real estate it's all paid for and I
never borrowed a dime on any of it they
ain't taking this one
this one's mine me and God were managing
this no Bankers involved this is the
Ramsay show